so next is May
Mak so hi I'm AI student decent advice
by and this is work with him but really
it's based on 20 years of influential
papers in this area many authors are in
this room um okay so we know data
management and just this simple process
can get us a lot of good analysis and
depending on how complicated your input
transformation output is you can do a
lot of very powerful and useful things
and extract information right but
sometimes you do this whole process and
you're like I don't understand this
output what what happened I didn't
expect to get this what went wrong and
what should my input have been to get
the output that I wanted right so
somehow want to go back in reverse and
reason about your input in terms of the
output that you've gotten and you don't
understand and this was formalized as
reverse data management in um 2011 by
Alexandra melu and her collaborators and
the idea of reverse data management is
to sort of ask what interventions or
what changes would you need in the input
to get the output that you desired or
expected right and this is a very
general framework that can encapsulate a
lot of important problems in database
Theory so I will'll talk about a few for
example deletion propagation studied
since the 80s by the and Bernstein and
um the question is really like if you
have some output and you want to delete
some Row from it like for gdpr reasons
right what change would you need to make
in the input and you can have different
objectives with this maybe you want to
change as little in the input as
possible possible or maybe you want as
little um output change right as little
side effects as possible and this was
studied in the dichotomy was given by
Peter baman and collaborators in
2002 right another important problem we
care about fairness right so we get some
output and with different fairness
metrics perhaps we want some probability
distributions or satisfy some hard
constraints we want to check is the
output fair and if not how close is it
to being fair and this can also be
modeled in this reverse data management
framework
okay we've seen that we can use a
Provence semiring to compute a Provence
polinomial when we're running our query
right now what if I look at this
Provence expression and I want to find
the minimum version of this like a
smaller formula that is equivalent to it
then turns out what we show is you can
compute it by using different query
plans to get the minimal possible
version and you can model this as a
reverse data management problem as well
all right another example what if you
care about what inputs are responsible
for your data dat right how much does
some particular input doule matter
towards the output of your query and you
can formalize this and this was
formalized in 2010 based on har Notions
of causality and this can also be
modeled in this reverse data management
way okay so you have all of these
different problems that we'd like to
solve so for some fixed query I give you
some arbitrary database you produce the
output and then you want to run some
reverse data management problem it could
be the ones I mentioned it could be
something else that you care about um
and you want to solve this and when I
say fix s I'm just talking about data
complexity um and you want to solve this
and maybe it's an NP complete problem
right so the best you can really do is
solve it exactly pay exponential time or
you want to find some approximations in
P time this is something you could hope
to do the other thing you could do is
you could find some structure in your
query and find easy sub instances right
and these you want to solve exactly in P
time and another thing you want to do is
you want to find out where this border
is for different problems now what we
propose is one unified algorithm to do
all of the above
okay um okay but now before we study all
of this reverse data management Universe
right maybe it makes sense to look at
the simplest possible reverse data
management problem you can think of and
this was proposed to be uh this question
of okay what minimum change would it
take to just delete all of your output
right and uh this problem was proposed
in 2015 by sabali far and co-authors as
resilience and you can see this is
already a very powerful problem right so
you can diagnose points of failure and
turns out this is equivalent to deltion
propagation with source side effects
that's been studied for a long time okay
so I will focus on resilience for the
rest of the talk but I want to convey
that this unification algorithm that we
propose is general and we hope can be
applied to all of these problems okay so
let me give you an example for
resilience pretend you're a data analyst
right you have access to people watching
movies and you also know that people
what items they buy and you also know
the product placement so you know that
items were featured in this movie now if
you have these three tables you can ask
a query like oh what person watches a
movie and then buys an item from it
right and this is an important question
a data analyst could ask but if you're a
theoretician all I've said here is
pretend you have a triangle query right
so let's say you have a triangle query
uh now you want to find you have some
data you want to find the resilience of
this right so you can compute your
output you get your output rows and you
have your domain values in dupal and
what you can also do is represent this
as a query hyper graph right so now
within this hypergraph you have your
hyper edges that are your Witnesses and
you want to find the resilience so what
minimum tles do I need to delete to make
the output false or to delete all hyper
edges right and this is the transversal
number of the hyper hypergraph so
essentially you just need to delete
these two tles and your resilience value
is to okay okay by minimal mean minimal
number of
modifications
Set uh the minimum number yeah okay so
turns out for the triangle query this
problem is empty complete um you can't
do any better than that and we've looked
at the triangle query a lot but there's
also this extension you can just add one
atom here and get the triangle un query
and turns out for this you can solve
this in p time and this was discovered
in the 2015 paper all right so what are
the results right so what is known for
self-join free queries um it was shown
in
2002 that if you have just project um
join queries in general this problems
andp hard right but you can find sub
classes of queries so in
2015 um there was linear query shown and
the intuition here I won't get into it
but the intuition here is that you have
a joint path instead of a joint Tre um
so these are in P time plus there's
another class that can be converted to
linear queries and these are in P time
as well um and so the resilience for set
semantics we have a dichotomy but what
was not studied was bag semantics so
imagine you want to have different
movies have multiple product placements
or you have weights or probability
distributions in somewhere right you can
only model this with bag semantics and
turns out we get a different dichotomy
for that with the unified approach okay
what else do we know so how do we solve
this problem so for self-join free
queries um you can have different
flow-based encoding so the idea really
is to take your problem convert it to a
flow graph and find mincut and somehow
this helps you find the resilience um
for if you want to do exact evaluation I
guess you could always Brute Force but
there wasn't anything specific studied
neither were approximation studied um if
you have self joints now this is still
open but there are some restricted
results in this 2020 paper by sbali and
collaborators that show that you can
have some flow algorithms for specific
classes of queries okay uh what we
propose is one approach that can solve
the exact and easy self-join or
self-join pre queries and I will talk a
bit about how we do this all right so
previously set semantics we also
enlarged to bag semantics and we can do
all subjoin sub joint fre queries now
the interesting thing is if you have a
functional dependency you can modify
your flow-based algorithm to take that
into account what our algorithm hopes to
do is that if you have functional
dependencies even if they're unspecified
but they exist in the data the algor
automatically leverages this so you sort
of take advantage of structuring the
data without explicitly defining the
structure okay um now all of these
approximations and details I won't speak
so much about in this talk what I really
like to communicate is two key ideas
that make this approach unified and um
that's that's the main takeaway but I'm
happy to go into more detail
afterwards okay so what is the unified
algorithm essentially it's a integer
linear program we have seen these many
times before um you have some
constraints and some linear objective
that you would like to solve and we want
to take our resilience problem and model
it as an integer linear program so let's
take the same example our constraints
are that for each hyper Edge you want to
delete some tle right so we have three
different con Str here that say for all
the three Witnesses you must delete at
least one of the doubles um what do we
minimize we minimize the number of
topples deleted all right so this clear
and for each topple either you delete it
it's uh one or you don't delete it it's
zero so this is the integer part of the
program and if you solve this you will
get the answer too all right now what if
you had self joints right you do the
exact same thing the same encoding but
now you don't get the same AR necess in
the constraints you can have different
variables for constraint but it's the
same procedure and if you have back
semantics we show that all you need to
do is you need to add the number of
copies in the objectives and that's it
th those are the only sort of things you
need to make it more General right and
now uh if you set the values of F1 and
B2 to one then you do get the same
resilience that we saw earlier and all
of this works okay so uh now the other
thing is you can take away the grity uh
constraint and get a relaxed linear
program and um you would get a
fractional solution this would be a
natural low bound because you're taking
away some constraints and you can obtain
a lower Bound for resilience okay all
right now what is the unified algorithm
you take your query you take your
database you build an ILP like this and
you put in a solver now I know what
you're thinking ILP is inp hard right so
how do you recover all P time cases and
P time like what is going on here okay
so now here is the interesting part we
show term that for all known P time
cases the objective of the ILP is the
same as the objective of the lp right um
and I will just refer to this is LP
equal to ILP um so okay we have this
very nice term that okay for all these
easy cases if you just solve the
relaxation that's enough but now I'm
proposing that oh you just put in a
solver and that's it you don't how do
you know whether to solve an LP or an
ILP right so this is how a Sol Works
sort of grobi works internally is that
first they solve the linear programming
relaxation and then they sort of do a b
branch and bound approach based on the
lp solution that they've obtained um so
now if you get a solution that's exactly
equal to the lp relaxation you don't
need to explore the whole Space you're
sort of done right and you have your
integral answer in P time if it's equal
to the lp objective so this is really
the trick that we're using to make
solvers do the the hard work for us okay
so now we still have one problem how do
we prove that LP equal to ILP right like
this is still left we have an algorithm
but we need a proof and um there's a lot
of work done since many many years on
this very important question and there
are known cases like totally unimod
balance there's textbooks written about
this
stuff turns out we had easy cases ptime
cases that were not totally unimodal
that were not Balan that did not fit any
of these Frameworks okay how do we go
from here how do we prove that LP equal
to LP so here's the interesting idea is
that we use this correspondence to flow
that was known earlier right and we
build a onetoone correspondence from the
ILP to the flow graph that was known
earlier and we say hey if the ILP has a
certain solution then the flow graph has
a certain cut and they correspond
exactly so because we know this problem
can be encoded as a slow graph we just
know that the lp will equal to the ILP
and we don't actually need to build a
slow graph while calculating the
resilience or anything this is just a
proof we just need to convince ourselves
about the existence of such a flow graph
and we're done here right so this is
sort of the way we can use a unified
approach right so that was the unified
algorithm I will now talk about the
unified hardness proof right so we've
convinced ourselves that we can solve it
but when can we actually show LP equal
top all right so how do you usually show
hardness right you take some hard
problem you have some Gadget and you
reduce it to the problem that you want
to show as hard okay uh so if you have
vertex cover let's say you get some
arbitrary graph you want to convert it
to a problem that we care about you want
to convert it to resilience and you want
to build some database that will have a
resilience that is some known function f
of the vertex cover right so you need to
be able to recover the Vex cover from it
okay and now generally you define an
edge Gadget so for single edge you map
it to a database in some way and this is
your Edge Gadget now it was conjectured
in the P 20 paper that you can use
independent joint parts and we sort of
changed the definition a little bit that
I can go into detail on later but if a
query forms an independent joint B more
on this uh then it is NP complete and
the idea has to use this independent
joint path as an edge Gadget okay so
what is the independent joint path the
way we Define it it's a database with
some endpoints but it has five testable
properties right so the first is that
common sense it's connected second it's
it's reduced so every double
participates and some witness um then
the third thing is that the end points
have valid which for the purposes of
this do I would say just think of it as
the end points are of of the same
relation right so you can sort of join
them if need be okay now there's two
more properties that are defined
semantically and uh these are sort of
captured the core of the vertex cover
problem so the first is the r property
and then you have to compose these edges
in some way okay so what is the r
property so Vex cover the way you do it
is for every Edge you want to pick a or
b right so this is the key property you
need in vertex cover we want to find
something analogous for resilience right
so what we say is do not delete at least
one side or the other right now so in
vertex cover what you don't allow is
that you don't want that you have don't
pick a and don't pick B right now if in
this resilience example you delete both
uh S1 and SP you haven't deleted your
middle hyperedge right and what this
means is that you need a resilience of
three this is not minimal the minimal
resilience needs only two so in Vex
cover you're violating your constraint
and here for resilience you're violating
minimality in some way so this is the
correspondence that we want to draw the
okay case is when you pick one of the
two sides of vertex cover and you delete
one of the two sides in your igp okay
and you check all four possibilities you
check that they correspond and you get
the resilience that you want and if you
have this then we say we have the orb
property okay the second property that I
mentioned is composability
so the Vex cover of one graph plus
another gives you some graph right
similarly you need to be able to take
one igp plus another and get a combined
igp right and this combined igp should
not have any extra Witnesses being
formed due to Joint dependencies right
you don't want to add two graphs and
then get some extra edges um so
composing these two igps in any any
possible way should not lead to extra
Witnesses this is another property that
we want okay so now we have defined some
Notions of igps and we now want to find
some way of finding these igps right so
our dream is to sort of take a query
automatically find some independent
joint path and then show that okay this
query is hard how do we do this okay so
turns out what we also need for now is
the domain size how big do you want this
hardness proof to be more on this in bit
but then you have your Gadget and you
can just go through an exponential space
of databases right and sort of guess an
igp and then you verify is this a valid
igp or not right for all possibilities
now how do you verify you check if it
has the or property that I spoke about
and you check if it composes in some way
right so for the or property what you
need to do is look at four possibilities
and find the resilience in each and see
if it has the or property or not and
what this turns out to be equivalent you
find you're solving for NB problems um
that does it have a resilience of size
scale and you're solving for Co NP
problems does it not have a resilience
of size K minus one right okay and the
way we think we need more expressivity
is because you're solving four NP and Co
NP problems as a sub routine so you need
something the second polinomial order to
be able to do this automatically in some
way right now for composing there are
many possible ways you could compose
right so do we need to check all
exponential ways in which igps could
compose turns out no turns out all you
need to do is check the interaction
between three igps in this specific way
where you have like all possible
variations of the input arrows and if
these if this graph composes then that's
sort of all you need and you will always
have composability so this is something
you can easily
check right so because we need to be
because we think we need something in
the second polinomial order we use this
idea uh we use disjunctive logic program
that actually has this expressivity and
we use this a very neat trick called
saturation that was discovered in the
90s and it's sort of like um what Max
spoke about equality saturation except
you saturate your model with all
possible answers and you use the minimal
model semantics of anet programming to
be able to solve NP and Co andp problems
as a sub routine so a very neat sort of
idea that we use in building our program
right now with this program that we buil
we were actually able to prove hardness
for queries that were open so all of
these figures are sort of queries whose
hardness was not known and there were
seven open listed cases in the 2020
paper and we were able to show that five
of them are actually hard and if you
look at all of these uh then you can
sort of check that you can compose them
in any way and they have the or property
and essentially you can just plug it
into a proof with Vortex cover and you
can show that you get an end to end
proof saying that this squ is
hard to check I understand correctly
this like like higher level of the
hierarchy kind of complexity is not the
complexity of the problem
like The Meta problem of figuring out
the given query yes yes and uh yes so
this is the complexity of the meta
problem you're right and I also want to
mention that this is uh not a lower
bound or anything this is just the way
we can do it right now it's possible you
can do it faster but this is the way we
know how to do it and it works sort of
in practice to help us F find hardness
for open questions okay and now the
interesting thing is for all previously
known hard queries you can recover
hardness Plus you can find these
interesting new cases okay so now we
have some terms and conjectures so we
know that if you have this independent
joint B that's sort of enough to prove
hardness you can build end to improve we
also know that for self joint free
queries this is the only thing you need
so if you don't have an igp then it's
not hard this is sort of the only
hardness property you need now what we
conjecture is that for all queries
including self joints I JPS are sort of
all you need right so we really think
that this is a universal hardness
Criterion that you can automate and what
we also think is that if you have an igp
so this is when I'm talking about the
domain size we think that you only need
to look up to a restricted domain size
and this is enough so you don't need to
check the space of all exponential many
igps but you just need to go up to a
certain size and if you have a hardness
roof by then that's it otherwise you
don't need to check everything so what
this means means is you can actually
automate it so if if both of these
conjectures were true then all you would
need to do is really run our DLP and if
it returns something it's hard otherwise
it's not so this is something that we
believe and I propose all right now the
other thing that we believe is that if
there's no igp then you can solve it
with NLP right so for all non easy cases
it's true that LP equal to ILP but we
believe that for all easy cases LP equal
to ILP and this is something we think
will help as a universal algorithm all
right we also think that if there is no
igp Then There exists some flow encoding
and we can use that flow encoding as a
proof so this is this big table of
conjectures so what are the takeaways
here so we have a unified algorithm and
the cool thing is that's all you need
but now you need to show that I actually
is speed time right so if you have an
easy case you already know how to solve
it you just need to prove that it's easy
so it's this change in perspective right
and the other unification is that of the
hardness Criterion and because of it we
are allowed automatic search and that
should help make finding hardness cases
easier now the other thing is how can we
extend this so I only spoke about
resilience we also apply this approach
to causal responsibility and get sort of
the same thing that for all known P time
cases LP uh the so there we get the
mixed ingal inm program equal to ILP but
it's the same idea and we're able to use
igps as well similarly for minimal
factorization we can also sort of use
these same unified ideas and there is um
I claim that many more problems that we
care about in database Theory can be
tackled with a very similar unified
approach and a lot more details
experiments approximations are all
available online thank
you
so this very interesting right but uh
like one one idea is like we propos is
to extel to ball of problems right
another one might be to increase the
class of queries do you see any hopes
there to go
beyond the class of support uh so do you
have an example for what sort of R maybe
things where we introduce some limited
type of agation for example or negations
foro window I don't know but I think
negation is not out of the window
actually um I think this so the approach
uh can be extended to uh the queries and
my intuition for this is so for these
examples that I spoke about causal
responsibility and minimal
factorization yes so so already in the
ILP they have negation so the
constraints you need to introduce
negatives which is not the case in
resilience problems and the approaches
still work so the lp equal to ILP stuff
still works and for the igps as well
like maybe the or property will have to
be defined differently but I think this
overall idea would still
work um so so I think a unified approach
like this is very appealing I wonder
with respect to the extension to other
problems while the encoding may work it
may not be the most efficient or
practical thing to do like you know for
example say if you see data gener as a
reverse data management
problem you want your data to satisfy
to like your constraints can grow with
the size of the data right so so then
maybe the encoding just becomes too
large right so yes it's it's possible
that for all for all problems this might
not be the most efficient encoding I
would say two things here so the first
is that if indeed your problem is in a
lower fine grain P time complexity class
and ilps are well be complete maybe you
can indeed do better but in most cases
um what what we're sort of using here is
that ILP solvers are there's been a lot
of work done on them and sort of if you
don't care about developing hero stics
for your problem or you don't care about
you know putting in a lot of your own
expertise domain knowledge you can
already use existing knowledge in IP
solers and just sort of blackbox take
advantage of it um so that sort of is
the other
Advantage yeah I find this very
interesting my question is also about
extending the language of queries and
like the one class I would have in mind
would be like recursive queries like
rpqs data log and so on and seeing a bit
about the techniques that you use at
least to show hardness I get the
impression that if you have this gadget
having these properties that you have
hardness of the query and then you
really need to care that the query is a
ucq or can you just rely on some
semantic properties of the query to be
able to use these gadgets so of course
what I have in mind is homomorphism
close queries because I've done
something have a work like this we have
we just use the fact that the quer
isomorphism cl we don't care in which
language it is supposed and so I'm
wondering if the the same approach could
be used here to get essentially for free
hardness results for more General
queries so I haven't thought about
recursive queries um very deeply but I
so my intuition is that it works simply
because the last two properties are
defined semantically right so we say
that oh if it has an R property and if
it composes then it's sort of an igp but
maybe the the theorems that we use for
showing composability are different in
different query settings maybe the way
you show the R property is different in
different query settings but because
this portion is sort of defined
semantically and we're just sort of
saying that hey these are the properties
that we want for our reduction to work
that's why I think it might be able to
generalize it's still very much future
work okay great then let's take half an
hour break and we going to ring the bell
thank
you